foreign
let's go to Donna in Lexington let's
just move on from here Donna what's up
hi wow I am talking to John deloney no
way I'm talking to Donna this is
incredible how's it going
great great excellent excellent what's
happening
well my question is how do I have a
fulfilling passionate marriage when both
me and my husband have different
attachment Styles oh no are you an
attachment style person
unfortunately
jeez attachment style people I here's my
my picture in my head there's attachment
style people and uh
Enneagram people and they put on those
medieval clothes and they fight like in
the public park with wooden sticks
that's what I imagined in my head
LARPing yes
I don't even know that there's a word
for that so congratulations so you're an
attachment style person
um okay so tell me more about it is one
of you anxious and one avoidant or one
of you secure in one of you anxious or
or you've got different attachment
Styles and it's all coming down
well we've been having symptoms of sort
of communication mishaps for the years
that we've been married uh and one day I
decided hey there's got to be something
to it and I took a quiz online to solve
all my life's problems yes the online
quiz
yes uh and found that I was anxious
attachments so I sent it to my husband
and he was avoidant
and that explained a lot of things in
our marriage and it really helped us to
communicate better
but it hasn't really solved
um
I guess
my issues and his issues which are
I guess I get this empty feeling when
I'm not getting connection right and so
I go and I chase for it and then when I
chase he
hides runs and it's very
difficult yes you'll end up in the dance
right
um that so many couples end up in it's
just the dance one's chasing one's
hiding and it just works like on an
infinity loop and then you find each
other and you connect and it's going to
be this way forever and it's awesome so
hey um I was poking fun at you at the
beginning
um John bolby is is a famous British
psychologist he he
came up with this idea of
um attachment theories attachment ideas
and there are some great uh validity to
them I I I actually think that they've
got they're good to know and good
understanding and the great Mary
Ainsworth took those and expanded on
them they're good stuff
what I don't like about them the same as
I don't care for the Enneagram the same
as I don't care for most
um not what I would call mental health
Diagnostics like if you've got severe
mental health disorders or some or
personality disorders they can be very
helpful but just run of the mill I've
got depression I got anxiety the reason
I don't like them
um I especially things like Myers-Briggs
they they become well that's just who
this guy is
I'm a this guy and she's this gal and so
you know
and so I think they can be good for
reflective tools
an online quiz like oh I I fall into
this bucket
but none of that matters when it comes
to looking at the person across from you
and saying
what do you need how can I love you
better today
regardless of quote unquote how it makes
me feel now of course this can be taken
to an extreme you know someone's like I
need sex four times every day right
that's insane right or I need you to
quit your job and it can get it can get
way out of bounds and so I'm I'm asking
everybody listening to be reasonable
here but
um
I my wife and I have very similar dance
that you and your husband have okay
which is I am anxiously avoidant I'm a I
have a terror um I'm fearful of
rejection and when I come on like I've
gotta I I come in hot I got a uh a lot
of energy and her body says get out of
here Hide
and it and then it sets all my alarms
off which then in turn sets her alarms
off then we have one big anxious house
right and then we try to solve it
through
our various you know addiction ways we
cover up things right so um what I'd
love to do is actually just just for to
placate me
um
where's your where does your anxious
attachment come from do you have
somebody leave you in childhood was was
connection weaponized as a child
definitely
um
dads okay Dad not in my life uh First
Love was pretty much uh my teenage First
Love Was a Serial cheater and physically
abusive
um
so yeah I had a little rough go of it
growing up but I think as much as I like
to say I'm over a lot of things I can
see the symptoms of what and I don't
like to uh be the victim in this
situation I don't like to think like
that but I do recognize the symptoms of
ways that
uh those things have affected me and my
relationships as an adult so I want to
give you some peace I want to give you
some peace because you said thinking
these type of anxious anxiety responses
are at the nervous system level
and so you can think through no no I've
got a good one now
like this guy's the good guy he's he's
the one he's not one of my stepdads he's
not going to leave you can think that
cognitively and you probably did because
you wouldn't have married him but your
body put a GPS pin and Men Who are
supposed to keep you safe or men who say
the words I love you or men who say the
words I care about you and to put a GPS
pin in them and said watch out
they're gonna leave they're gonna hit
you they're gonna cheat on you're gonna
destroy you
and so there we hear the fight or flight
all the time but there's fight flight or
freeze and then there's another one
that's that's I don't say it's rare but
we just don't talk about it very much
it's fight fight or fawn
I'm gonna get so nuzzled up and close to
you I'm going to be overly intimate
overly connected that'll keep me safe
surely you won't he hit me or cheat on
me if I'm if I'm really really close to
you right and of course that that can be
insane but it but it can work too right
so
you're what's happening to you is at the
nervous system level I want to honor
that
and probably uh where's your husband's
um he's not here to speak for himself
but where does his root from have y'all
talked about that oh yeah well he's
wonderful and his family is wonderful
but
very
con other than the controlling aspect so
I think he uh I love a good anxious
avoidant person like they hit me but
they do it gently and it doesn't always
hurt right you're trying to make sure
all the relationships are fine they're
fine because they don't want them to
leave right
um so maybe they are sweet and they were
hyper controlling and when people are
hyper controlling usually that means
they're the performance of the people
they're in relationship is going to
determine how uh how much love there is
to go around or not
and it's easier for him or they're just
hyper hyper critical critical critical
why are you wearing that why are you
doing oh my gosh why are you fixing your
hair like that did you brush your teeth
did you and then that body checks out
he's probably pretty talented at being
um completely alone in a crowded room
huh
very much so yeah you nailed it there
yeah he can he can go inside of himself
is what I say so again uh let's throw
let's throw attachment Styles off okay
we got that figured out you you your
body tells you when you get anxious we
got to get really close and his body
tells him when he's anxious we gotta get
far away
okay so the goal here is not to fight
attachment
attachment Styles the goal here isn't to
um
make each body feel unsafe all the time
it's actually the opposite the goal here
is to teach our body the thing that kept
us safe When We Were Young is what's
destroying our relationships in the
present
and so we have to teach our body that we
weren't safe then but we are safe now
in that just it's a skill so he's not
broken you're not broken your bodies are
doing exactly what they should they're
trying to protect you they've seen this
before when you come in and you're like
oh honey honey and you're all anxious in
a super attached probably you're asking
him why he's wearing that belt and why
are you wearing those socks with that
shirt that isn't even and he's like and
he just disappears and you and here's
what's crazy people with anxious
attachment they know when the person
leaves even though they're in the middle
of a conversation you can feel them
evaporate in front of you they just they
just go away but they're still talking
they're still engaged with you and you
know it and it makes you bananas and how
I know because that's me Donna we're the
same all right so here's what you have
to um both of you have to know
your anxiety
that you are trying to solve by nuzzling
by getting close to him by taking
dominion over him is what I'll say
trying to control him
that anxiety is getting stronger every
time you give into it
so this anxious attachment is going to
get Tighter and Tighter and Tighter over
the course of your marriage until one of
you just leaves
and I don't want to cast a shadow over
you guys or and when I say leaves that
could be literally they leave or they
just disappear in onto the couch behind
a six-pack right the other side of it is
he's got to understand that being not
being in true connection with somebody
will kill him physiologically his body
will die because his body knows you we
are all we got brother
it's just it's just us and us
and it will it will you've read the the
you've heard me talk all the time about
the the data on loneliness okay so
here's what both of you have to decide
to do
you have to decide we're going to enter
into a period of time and it could be a
short period of time a long period of
time then there's going to be some
crisis in your marriage so one of your
parents is going to get sick one of your
kids is going to say something's gonna
happen and your body's gonna want to
drag you back to what it knows and
you're gonna have to be really
intentional there
but here's how we're gonna we're gonna
move forward the first thing is we are
going to
consciously when our bodies start to
feel anxious we're gonna stop take a
huge deep breath as deep as we can we're
going to drop our shoulders let it out
and ask ourselves what are you trying to
protect me from here
what are you trying why don't I feel
safe right now oh because he just walked
into the other room okay he still loves
me he's still here we gotta check
ourselves every time
and this will be tedious this will be a
beating and he's gonna have to decide
every time he starts to unplug nope I'm
staying present I'm staying present what
I found is I was
too much for my wife and what she found
is she wasn't enough
and we had to meet somewhere in the
middle and now there's a safety
mechanism that she feels she now knows
when I'm about to pull away she actually
will lean in further and I know when I'm
about to lean in more I actually Retreat
and that's from I'm trying to meet her
need she's trying to meet my needs so
that I can meet her needs so that she
can meet my needs and it just stays on
this incredibly beautiful Loop does that
make sense
it does it does it sounds like a
long way to go to get there but I'm
really hopeful that we can do it yeah I
a hundred percent you can and
I think let's let's stop the attachment
language and let's start with
my body tells me I'm not safe when you
pull away and you're going to know what
those pull away things are write them
down write them down and talk to them be
open about them when you do this when
you do this when you do this my wife has
told me when you stomp when you when I
come into the house I just walk really
heavy when I walk into the house boom in
my uh living room is suspended over the
garage and so it it just moves through
the house
it just sends her body it just she's
like I gotta get out of here and when I
see her like make eye contact with me in
Bolt I don't know why my body's like
she's gone forever she's not she's not
and so we I we've had to sit down and
say
here's the things that make me feel
unsafe
and so when I come in not always but
often she'll stop and come give me a hug
when I wake up in the morning she'll
stop and give me a hug not because
that's what she wants to be doing
she's got a whole list of things she'd
rather be doing but because
I can I can draw my shoulders and vice
versa so all I have to say is I want you
guys to stop using attachment language
start being very clear about hey this
action you do makes me feel unsafe will
you lean in this way
this action makes me feel unsafe will
you lean in this way and if there's a
time when you start to feel
um
uh your body starts to feel anxious his
body starts to feel anxious
have uh give each other permission to
say my body is telling me that
I'm beginning to feel unsafe and
make that a part of your conversation in
your home and what you're going to find
at first is you're going to take it
personally like I feel awful that I'm
making you feel nobody's making us feel
anything it's just our body's trying to
protect us but that's how we're gonna
have to talk about it we have to bring
it to the light we have to say I don't
feel safe right now or my body's telling
me that you're walking away let's start
that language about how can I feel more
safe
and that's the path forward you may need
to get a book like one of these little
I gotta come up with a cool name for
this but a journal though you write
these things down or you take care of
yourself
body's trying to keep you safe that's it
she's doing its job now it needs to
learn a new way to keep you safe which
is in connection direct connection and
neither of you are using the other one
to meet your uh anxiety to to quell the
anxiety
you're with each other
fully intertwined on the same field